echten geisterfahrkarte hallo mein Name
ist Luca meine Damen und Herren herzlich
willkommen zu einem Video in dem Sandra
und ich unsere alten Grundschulen
besuchen werden wir haben ja vor ein
zwei Jahren schon mal unser Gymnasium
besucht ne wo wir unser Abi gemacht
haben
halt die Fresse da gibt's so Löcher da
kann man perfekt Zigaretten
[Musik]
die einzige bist du denn sandra war nur
an meiner Grundschule wir waren auch
zwei verschiedenen weil du hier mal
geraucht hast
[Musik]
mich komplett ein Bruder
der spinnt komplett also ich bin vor
sechs Jahren oder so mal gefahren
man muss ja einfach sagen wir sind
mittlerweile schon so fette Promis das
von uns überall erkennen wir können ja
nirgendwo mehr normal hingehen was macht
Revie denn hier sind auf jeden Fall
heute bisschen nostalgisch unterwegs und
werden euch unsere alte Grundschule
zeigen du warst auf einer anderen als
ich ich war auf dieser hier
müssen überlegen dass ich früher mit
meinen Eltern da hinten in seiner
Siedlung gewohnt habe also wir sind dann
halt irgendwann umgezogen hier war immer
so der Parkplatz hier waren die ganzen
Fahrräder dann angepackt ich bin immer
zu Fuß hin gelaufen
alle Fahrradständer in unserem Dorf
sehen genauso aus auch an unserem
Gymnasium
hast du gefragt oder das hier habe ich
auf jeden Fall bei keiner anderen
Grundschule jemals noch mal gesehen und
zwar ist das ein abgesenkter Platz hier
wo man halt Spiele spielen kann und das
war halt richtig geil weil also das sind
hier so keine Ahnung was sind das so 20
30 cm oder so das ist halt immer der
Ball dann gegen gegangen der ist nicht
irgendwie krass weggeflogen
auf die Sporthalle geschossenhof so vor
der Eingangstür da kann ich euch auch
noch eine Story erzählen denn wegen mir
wurde mal die komplette Eingangstür neu
gebaut gar keine Platten ich glaube wir
hatten die noch nicht in der Grundschule
die haben wir mal Rundlauf gespielt und
dann immer schön mit dem Becken da so
dran kommen Alter also halb sterben dann
immer Fang Verstecken gespielt oder wie
das hieß also hier war immer eine Person
hingestellt muss diese beide Hände dran
halten und ziehen und halt gegen die
Wand gucken dann rufen sie alle
verstecken verstecken
du hast gar nichts gefunden wurde muss
man abschlagen aber muss man dann immer
hi
arbeitest du hier
ah okay ich dachte wir kriegen auf jeden
Fall der Eingang zu unserer Sporthalle
1877 diese Toiletten hier vorne hat nie
jemanden
die alle krank
es war krass Schule
jedenfalls war das hier dann halt so der
Eingang und früher war es dann wirklich
so dass nicht wie bei einer Uni die
machen die Toren auf und alle kommen
irgendwie eine Viertelstunde halbe
Stunde zu spät sondern hier haben die
Leute halt wirklich damals noch gewartet
also ich auch als ich klein war um halt
rein zu kommen wenn man sich so auf die
Schule damals noch gefreut hat und hier
das haben die mittlerweile Weg gemacht
eben wegen mir wann früher so Gitter
damit man dort hat seine Schuhe
abklopfen konnte und halt so direkt
dahin konnte etc pp ich habe im Winter
als wir halt auch gewartet haben als die
Schule noch geschlossen hatte aufgrund
von wir waren zu früh da habe ich im
Wettrennen gemacht mit Dominik Kollege
von mir ganz liebe Grüße das sieht der
ist jetzt irgendwo in Bayern runter
glaube ich dann Wettrennen gemacht wer
als erstes von dort hinten von der
Absperrung hier
mit seinem Hoverboard kommt
zurückgefahren jedenfall von hier vorne
ein Wettrennen gelaufen wäre als erstes
dort an der Tür war und ich wollte
abbremse und bin über diese Gitter rüber
gestellt ich glaube schon mal Podcast
erzählt damit ich mit meinem Knie in die
Scheibe rein dann ist die Tür gesprungen
Fall wegen mir meine Eltern mussten
Video möchte
grüßen meine Familie
[Musik]
glückwunsch
ich hatte hier eine Pizza moin
seitdem du hier nicht mehr raus sind
auch keine kippenstänge mehr hier hinten
rum war dann unsere Laufbahn also hat
man dann diese Bundesjugendspiele
Scheiße
der kann weiter ein Ball werfen vorne
sondern überall so Wege um halt über die
Schule an alle Sachen ranzukommen ich
weiß oder sind wir in meiner Dritte oder
vierten Klasse sind auch immer rum
geklettert immer einer Pause und dann
übelst Anschiss bekommen seitdem ist
auch alles Video überwacht tatsächlich
wegen mir haben die einiges verändert
nein nein das sind meine
Kinder deswegen war aber wirklich der
beste Klassenraum weil man konnte halt
hier sitzen und konnte halt hier dann
aber den Leuten immer so ein bisschen
beim Sport zu gucken wer hat natürlich
Sporthalle und hier vorne war auch noch
der Sportplatz
[Musik]
einmal hier gespielt so
Ärger bekommen
hier vorne sind auf jeden Fall auch noch
Klassenräume gewesen das ist die Küche
das war mein erster Klassenraum da war
meine da war ich zum ersten Mal drin da
war ich erste Klasse
einmal hier komplett außen rumgelaufen
hier ist wieder der Pausenhof da vorne
war der Eingang hier war die Kletterwand
da bin ich auch mal fett runtergeflogen
und das war meine erste Klasse da war
mein erster Klassenraum denn wie gesagt
Spielplatz und so da hat sich aber alles
verändert also da hatten wir früher ganz
andere Sachen das waren gefühlt
foltermaschine aber ansonsten war das
meine Schule und ich würde sagen wir
fahren jetzt mal zusammen als
Grundschule ne
so Leute jetzt sind wir an meiner
Gesamtschule
Grundschule wurde jetzt aber komplett
übernommen von unserem Gymnasium
und direkt daneben was Sandra das
Grundschule ich kann mich direkt noch an
diesen Stern erinnern
das ist eine Sonne
damit habe ich immer gespielt
schön ohne Witz ich will ein
Bürgermeister bauen
man kann da unten sind Klassenräume
dicker
ja bei den Musikraum ist ein
Klassenzimmer
[Musik]
ab und zu
verstecken
[Musik]
dieses fette Dinge war auf jeden Fall
die Sporthalle von unserem Gymnasium und
das hier war die Sporthalle von der
Grundschule daneben die auch wieder
Klassenräume von innen gesehen hat
Förderkurs aber um mich zu fördern aber
wirklich war ich gut war der ich waren
zum erdkundekurs Geographie der hat hier
stattgefunden und das war nicht
normalerweise Leute ja aber ich glaube
hier steht natürlich auch wieder gute
Schule no joke Leute das sagen euch
wahrscheinlich alle und ihr hört sich
bei habe selber früher nicht auf meine
Eltern gehört als die meinten genießt
die Schulzeit aber genießt die Schulzeit
no joke was wir jetzt alles für Probleme
haben die ihr euch nicht kümmern muss
war alles mit Steuern mit dem
Versicherungen mit also Sachen die man
sich kümmern muss das hatte die denken
noch ein bisschen so Silicon Valley wenn
man sich das da so anguckt ne so
Grünfläche können die Schüler sitzen und
lernen machen aber das ist hier oggs
damit hatte ich nie was zu tun damals
dachte ich dass
üblicher Berg
als Kindermann generell so ein paar
Sachen völlig überschätzt
das war nur ein Hase dann hat ein
bisschen Schiss wegen dem Hasen aber
hier vorne war angeblich mal Spielplatz
wie gesagt es ist halt jetzt Teile des
Gymnasiums geworden deswegen ist sie
wahrscheinlich jetzt kein Spielplatz
mehr logischerweise aber so ein paar
Sachen stehen dir noch z.B Spielplatz
für Kinder unter 14 Jahren nicht
gestartet und sowas da gibt's aber
irgendwie alles nicht mehr also ihr
merkt schon Sandras Schule hat sich
krass entwickelt die haben natürlich so
ein bisschen dadurch profitiert jetzt
dass sie halt aufgekauft wurden vom
Gymnasium nebenan aber so ein bisschen
Vergangenheit und Nostalgie geht dadurch
natürlich verloren bei mir ist alles
halt noch fast genauso wie früher das
ist schon sehr sehr cool aber gut
Freunde wenn es euch gefallen unseren
alten Grundschulen waren dann lassen wir
einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video hier
da abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt
selbstverständlich auf diese scheiß
Glocke werden immer noch nicht was dann
bringt aber macht man ne Revie hat die
letzten Worte